préservatif vison longue galerie oh non
finalement on va en chercher 24 des
préservatifs
[Musique]
mais j'ai rien à faire ici en fait
histoire de papoter un peu quoi et ça se
voyait légèrement en fait il
s'en foutait totalement en fait c'est
lui raconter regarde
quoi si je voulais un amant ça fait
longtemps que je pratique
du colza qui est plus en fleur et
l'autre il est voilà et moi moi c'est
pareil il est en stade comme ça du coup
est-ce que tu as envie de me connaître
ou pas
ou pas du coup
je vais te faire voir le blé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
un petit plaisir
dans la dans la voiture sous les yeux de
l'autre prétendantes qui leur faisait à
manger regardez c'est la meuf la moins
lucide du monde que vous allez voir
en position ok tu imagines
[Rires]
[Musique]
il y a encore pas fait son choix
[Rires]
j'avais juste 20 ans mais c'était dans
un parking souterrain c'était pas très
romantique
[Rires]
à l'arrière ou à l'avant on avait fait
un peu comme ça
allez on termine avec Clément il a 26
ans il a jamais eu de copine de sa vie
ça va à 26 ans ça va ça passe il est
mignon voilà comme c'est mignon il a
plein de prétendantes dont une
Anne-Laure qui a passé son temps à faire
un rire assez chelou regardez
un petit cadeau voilà
[Rires]
merci toi aussi
[Musique]
[Rires]
moi j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire
on est cohérent je trouve donc
ça se passe bien
c'est comme j'espère
[Applaudissements]
ils vont bien ensemble franchement
j'ai rien dit moi justement
montre un truc il y a une vidéo qui fait
actuellement le tour des réseaux sociaux
j'adore les mecs qui disent ça le tour
des réseaux sociaux ça fait un buzz on y
voit des robots se préparer pour un
match de football américain et vous
allez voir la réalité c'est qu'en fait
c'est une mise en scène pour un film de
science-fiction mais on a l'impression
que c'est des vrais c'est un truc de fou
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des humains c'est Disney on peut le dire
qui a fait ça pour son film de
science-fiction qui va sortir bientôt et
ça se passe évidemment dans un stade de
Los Angeles tout près de Hollywood donc
ça a fait un buzz mondial mais on dirait
vraiment des humains moi c'est ça qui
m'effet s'appelle The Creator le film
alors certaines vidéos de robots sont
par contre réel et font bien flipper
comme si avec ce robot qui réalise des
figures et des backflips des backflip
parfaitement exécuté ça aussi on se dit
c'est un truc de fou c'est c'est un gars
et il y a même
la même des chiens robots qui font même
peur au vrai chien
[Applaudissements]
en plus c'est un mille-pattes qu'un
chien un chien sans tête bon voilà sans
que
c'est dur
est-ce que vous connaissez une nouvelle
méthode utilisée pour par certaines
municipalités pour réduire la vitesse
sur les routes elle consiste à peindre
des lignes dans tous les sens ou à
laisser passer au feu uniquement les
individus qui roulent à la bonne vitesse
regardez ça arrive ça et vous allez me
dire si vous êtes convaincu
des lignes blanches qui se croisent et
se courent dans le bourg de bonnet c'est
curieux spaghetti routier surprennent
les automobilistes depuis deux semaines
et les fonds ralentir pourtant je
connais la route mais le fait que on
sache pas finalement où sont les vraies
lignes c'est c'est ça fait ralentir ça
force à ralentir en France les communes
sont de plus
en pire les voitures
passage piéton en 3D ou lumineux la
commune de temple de Bretagne elle a
misé sur les feux récompenses devant les
écoles primaires le feu reste en
permanence au rouge si le véhicule
arrive à la bonne vitesse notamment là à
30 km/h le feu passe orange clignotant
comme on peut le voir là et le véhicule
peut passer truc de fou c'est génial moi
je trouve que c'est n'importe quoi
personnellement
en termes de radar par rapport aux
vitesses moi je suis pas pour limiter la
vitesse parce qu'on voit bien qu'en
Allemagne souvent la vitesse n'est pas
limitée notamment sur les autoroutes et
que ça pose pas problème en revanche je
suis plutôt pour mettre des petites
caméras pour pouvoir voir les
infractions qui modifient l'attention
c'est-à-dire le téléphone par exemple et
je pense que en plus en faisant ça en en
chassant par le téléphone au volant on
peut faire moins de
des fractions et donc du coup la limiter
les limiter les accidents plutôt que
gérer la vitesse moi je pense que c'est
exactement enfin moi je pense exactement
l'inverse parce que je pense que c'est
une idée géniale on sait depuis le
mouvement des gilets jaunes durant
lequel tu te souviens on avait mis tous
ses radars qui étaient qui étaient
cachés il y a eu des études qui ont été
faites à ce moment-là on se s'aperçu que
ça ne changeait absolument rien donc les
radars n'ont pas d'impact sur les
accidents ça n'a pas d'impact sur la
vitesse donc en revanche ça tous les
effets lumineux tous les effets visuels
on sait que c'est un impact immédiat les
gens perturbés réduisent leur vitesse
tout de suite mais le cerveau donc au
bout d'un moment si tu si voilà au bout
d'une semaine avec